corona ist leider nach wie vor ein
riesiges thema bei vielen von uns ist es
vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so präsent
wie noch vor einigen monaten aber nach
wie vor gucken experten jeden tag auf
die aktuellen zahlen um zu verstehen wie
sich das virus ausbreitet ein großer
teil dieser arbeit passiert dabei hinter
den kulissen wo epidemiologen unter
anderen modellen arbeiten die diesen
hier ganz unendlich sind jetzt gerade
ist es in deutschland entspannter als
noch zu beginn der pandemie
gott sei dank aber die große angst vor
einer zweiten welle ist nach wie vor da
und genau das versuchen experten gerade
vorher zu sagen gibt es eine zweite
welle und wenn ja wann kommt sie mit
solchen modellen kann man das zum
beispiel machen man kann es im verlauf
einer pandemie anschauen
hier ist es besonders interessant man
kann ein bisschen mit rumspielen sich
dann zum beispiel anschauen wie die
kontakt beschränkungen funktioniert
haben ungefähr so sah unsere kurve aus
ist kann man ja auch immer hier sehen
was aber passiert wäre wenn wir den
mehrwert nicht unter 1 gesenkt hätten
das kann man sich zb einfach mal ganz
einfach einen schieberegler ansehen und
das wissen wir alle exponentielles
wachstum es gibt wesentlich mehr
menschen in krankenhäusern und auch
wesentlich mehr tote
mit solchen oder ähnlichen modellen
haben epidemiologen schon anfang märz
vorausgesagt dass wir einiges am
öffentlichen leben ändern müssen um die
infektion einzudämmen
und wie es aussieht hatten sie damit
recht die mal als beispiel neben
deutschland die vereinigten staaten wo
der lockdown relativ schnell wieder
aufgelöst wurde und wer gar nicht so gut
durchgezogen wurde oder auch brasilien
muss noch schlimmer war
und natürlich muss man das ganze
vergleichen proben millionen einwohner
und dann sieht man ein ganz klarer
unterschied können also epidemiologen in
die zukunft schauen oder können wir dann
ausrechnen wann es eine zweite welle
geben wird dafür haben wir mit einem
epidemiologen gesprochen und zeigen wie
sie während einer pandemie zu sowas wie
gesundheits detektiven werben
unterdessen breitet sich das corona
virus immer schneller aus ich bin aber
sehr optimistisch dass wir die zweite
welle verhindern können
bis zu zwei stunden standen sie vor dem
corona testzentrum an
haben wir auch erwartet dass im herbst
die zahlen ein wenig hoch gehen
ich denke wir müssen schon jetzt ganz
vorsichtig sein
mit der entwicklung einer zweiten welle
in der epidemiologie dreht sich alles um
krankheiten und die frage was uns gesund
hält
dafür bauen epidemiologen modelle die
versuchen die ausbreitung einer epidemie
zu verstehen und einzuschätzen
das klingt jetzt alles super kompliziert
aber auch du hast schon modelle
ausgelesen zum beispiel beim regenradar
das ist nichts anderes als ein modell
das versucht die ursachen für
wetterverhältnisse zu erkennen und
daraus vorhersagen zu treffen wie sich
das wetter entwickeln könnte
die meisten infektionskrankheiten lassen
sich mathematisch modellieren
das heißt ihre eigenschaften können am
computer simuliert werden um zum
beispiel das verhalten eines virus zu
untersuchen und einzuschätzen
hier gibt es aber nicht eine goldene
formel die alle möglichen krankheiten
erklärt modelle sind oft bestimmte
infektionskrankheiten individuell
angepasst und es gibt eine vielzahl an
modellen die unterschiedlich komplex und
somit für unterschiedliche
fragestellungen geeignet sind häufig
verwendet man modelle die sich an
bestimmten kompartimenten also
zeitlichen abschnitten einer infektion
orientieren
ein gutes beispiel dafür ist das
sogenannte tiermodell rezepte exposed
infectious und ruft das neue virus zum
beispiel lässt sich mit einem tiermodell
beschreiben weil es eine inkubationszeit
hat in der infizierten sich angesteckt
haben aber noch nicht selber ansteckend
sind
dafür steht ex post würde gewinnt 19
keine inkubationszeit haben dann würde
ein zoll modell erreichen
über diese verschiedenen kontinente kann
man den anteil von personen in einer
bevölkerung berechnen die über einen
gewissen zeitraum die infektion
beschlossen
so lässt sich erkennen wann die
infektionszahlen ansteigen und wann sie
wieder abfallen diesen fall auf
darzustellen wäre zum beispiel ein sehr
standard mäßiges modell das
epidemiologisch wichtig ist uns schon
häufig benutzt wurde und wichtige fragen
beantworten kann man kann so ein modell
natürlich auch komplizierter machen
indem hat mir parameter mit rein bringt
zb wie bewegt sich ein individuum
wir sind die kontakte zwischen
altersgruppen oder zwischen ländlicher
und städtischer bevölkerung aber
versucht man dieses verhalten im
computer nachzubilden und dann zu gucken
wie sich die individuen untereinander
anstecken wird natürlich eine wesentlich
größere rechenleistung benötigt der
anderen seite klickt man natürlich auch
genauere ergebnisse um das alles noch
besser zu verstehen haben wir mit doktor
ralf kamp vom bernhard-nocht-institut
für tropenmedizin gesprochen
denn der arbeitet viel an modellen für
die ausbreitung von ebola man sie müssen
durch die faustregeln modell soll so
einfach sein wie möglich und so
kompliziert wie nötig also nicht jeder
andere fragestellungen muss man mit den
riesengrossen modell beantworten
manchmal reichen auch wirklich einfache
modelle um ganz klare frage stellen und
zu beantworten
einfache modell den vorteil die daten
sind schnell da das ist auch ein vorteil
sie sind wirklich transparent und man
kann sich leicht verstehen damit gut
interpretieren
und so schlagen sie auch nicht so
schnell fehler an desto weniger formeln
dessen weniger fehler kann sich
einbringen bevor epidemiologen durch die
statistische analyse und modelle
versuchen den problemen auf den zahn zu
fühlen und letztendlich herauszufinden
wie wir eine krankheit kontrollieren
oder besten fall sogar gänzlich stoppen
können brauchen sie allerdings 1 daten
besonders in den frühen stadien eines
ausbruchs ist es super wichtig nach zu
verfolgen wie die krankheit in eine
stadt region oder ein land gelangen
konnte so gewinnt apple die biologen
einerseits wichtige daten für ihre
modelle und lernen gleichzeitig etwas
über die ausbreitung der krankheit wie
ermittler an einem tatort suchen
epidemiologen nach hinweisen
systematisch versuchen sie fragen zu
beantworten wer ist krank was sind die
symptome
wann wurde die personen krank und vor
allem wo hat sich die person angesteckt
das ist waschechte detektivarbeit die
für corona in deutschland schon und
späten februar diesen jahres begonnen
hat
nach zwei unabhängigen geschäftsreisen
aus china und mailand den am 25
eine weitere anmeldung durch das land
das virus hat es nach nordrhein
westfalen geschafft und zwar in
als heinz infektionsketten seien
teilweise nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen
deutschland stehe vor einer epidemie
hier war das epizentrum der kogit 19
pandemie in deutschland denn die erste
große infektionskette startete mit einem
infizierten ehepaar im kreis heinsberg
einen tag später am aschermittwoch wird
klar was einige zeit vorher bei einer
karnevalssitzung in heinsberg passiert
ist 300 menschen auf engstem raum mit
den ersten beiden infizierten in
nordrhein westfalen
es wurde gesungen gelacht und getrunken
klar
zu diesem zeitpunkt hat natürlich noch
niemand an abstand und masken gebracht
und in den zwei wochen nach der feier
hat der ehemann viel kontakt zu anderen
menschen gehabt
all diese informationen sind das
ergebnis von contact tracing
epidemiologen und experten des
gesundheitsamtes haben sie kontakte des
infizierten paares gut verfolgt deswegen
sind schon zwei tage nachdem das virus
bei dem ehepaar festgestellt wurde
400 menschen in quarantäne gewesen und
das nicht nur von der karnevalsfeier
auch die kinder und das personal des
kindergartens in dem die infizierte
ehefrau arbeitet sind in quarantäne
gegangen es fanden aber weiterhin große
veranstaltungen statt
keine zehn kilometer von heinsberg
entfernt ab dem 8 märz wird klar dass
heinsberg nicht der einzige
infektionsherd ist skiurlaub südtirol
haben sich im großen stil angesteckt und
die infektion durch ganz deutschland
getragen
epidemiologen und ämter arbeiten jetzt
rund um die uhr um den infektionsketten
hinterher zu kommen leider springt die
ausbreitung ab einem bestimmten punkt
aber die kapazitäten das contact racing
wird schließlich mit stift papier und
einem telefon gemacht und oft können
sich infizierte ganz dann alle ihre
letzten kontakt erinnern
vor allem in den frühen phasen der
partie ohne kontaktverbot home office
oder schulschließungen sind menschen
vielleicht 150 leuten pro woche begegnet
hier hat sich schnell gezeigt dass die
digitale infrastruktur der ämter nicht
hinterherkommt wichtige informationen
wurden noch gefaxt
ja ja genau das alte klobige dingen was
bei den großeltern im arbeitszimmer
steht kontaktpersonen wurden wiederum
nur über telefon oder e-mail erreicht
das ist alles super aufwendig und
langsam aber nur weil man die
infektionskette nicht mehr nachverfolgen
kann gehen
die daten ja nicht aus ärzte und
krankenhäuser sind weiterhin
verpflichtet alle cool und 19 fälle an
das robert-koch-institut zu melden
mit diesen zahlen gelingt des
epidemiologen modelle aufzustellen
mittlerweile ist das contact racing
übrigens um einiges einfacher vor
redaktionsschluss von diesem video hier
am 27 juli haben bereits 16,4 millionen
bundesbürger die krone herunter geladen
die soll das verfolgen von kontakt
ketten wesentlich effizienter machen wie
die ab genau funktioniert und wie sicher
sie ist das haben wir übrigens in diesem
video hier erklärt der streit um die
korona fanta cola in die krone stichwort
heißt hier tracing generell gilt je
besser ausgearbeitet ein modell ist
desto komplizierter können die fragen
seien dies beantwortet nehmen wir mal an
in einem jahr haben wissenschaftler das
perfekte modell führt 19 entwickelt
haben wir dann also den code dieser
krankheit geknackt das würde bedeuten
dass krankheiten wie die spanische
grippe die menschheit härter getroffen
haben weil es keine epidemiologen gab
die damals in die zukunft der pandemie
schauen konnten
ich meine dann könnten wir theoretisch
jetzt schon herausfinden ob deutschland
noch eine zweite welle treffen wird oder
ja und nein
epidemiologen und ein fortgeschrittenes
gesundheitssystem geben uns auf jeden
fall einen gewaltigen vorteil gegenüber
krankheiten wenn man das zum beispiel
mit der spanischen grippe vor knapp 100
jahren vergleicht genauso wie globale
kommunikation besser regieren und
infrastruktur und die modelle die
epidemiologen bauen um eine panini
besser zu verstehen geben uns auch einen
gewaltigen vorteil aber auch einen blick
in die zukunft
es gibt den schönen satz der sagt alle
modelle sind falsch aber einige sind
hilfreich die glaubt man so ein bisschen
trifft den nagel auf den kopf kein
modell kann genau vorhersagen was mit in
zukunft passieren weil dann die klare
fragestellung haben dann können wir
modelle zu diesen fragestellungen
aufbauen und diese modelle können uns
helfen zu verstehen was passiert denn
eigentlich oder was sind wichtige grund
parameter mitgebrachten müssen
diese modelle werden uns nie sagen
können in vier monaten ist das ganze
vorbei wir müssen uns im winter keine
sorgen machen weil es gibt keine zweite
welle
wir können aber mit den modellen
herausrechnen was könnte dann eine
zweite welle sein was können und
parameter sein werden die zweite welle
begrüßt leben können oder wie konnte man
angehen um das ganze zu verhindern
das bedeutet nicht das modell sagt was
wir tun sollen aber das wurde kann uns
helfen zu verstehen und um modelle
hilfreicher und besser zu machen braucht
es einfach zeit im optimalfall ein oder
sogar zwei jahre um ein wirklich gutes
modell aufzubauen
jetzt hat die politik aber akute
fragestellungen und braucht am besten
gestern das erste modell
deswegen müssen wir uns erstmal auf
einfache schnell zu berechnende modelle
verlassen
ein modell bleibt aber am ende des tages
ein modell es ist keine glaskugel in die
wir hinein schauen können um klare
vorhersagen zu treffen
es bleibt eine hilfestellung
verschiedene modelle haben zum beispiel
verschiedene definitionen von begriffen
wie zum beispiel infiziert infiziert
bedeutet für die chinesische regierung
nur patienten mit symptomen
das habe eine beachtliche menge an
fällen gibt die symptomatisch also ohne
symptome an kurve 19 erkranken
fallen diese in china komplett durch das
raster hinzu kommt dass gemeldete zahlen
nur einen bruchteil der realen
fallzahlen abbilden und die sind ja
grundlage aller modelle in die zukunft
schauen können epidemiologen nicht das
ist unmöglich egal wie gut das modell
ist das heißt allerdings nicht dass
modelle uns nicht helfen können die
zukunft zumindest besser einzuschätzen
das finde ich erwartet habe eigentlich
an das was die wissenschaft leisten kann
die wissenschaft kann begleitenden die
wissenschaft kann aktuell der evidenz
zusammenfassen können versuchen so
müssten vorauszusagen was wäre wenn
und ich glaube das ist ein wunderbarer
schlusssatz vielen lieben dank doktor
wahlkampf für das super spannende und
mega ausführliche interview
danke schon auch für die hilfe bei der
recherche und falls euch jetzt
interessiert wie so ein typisches doktor
watson skript aussieht mit dessen hilfe
wir diese videos hier machen dann könnte
uns jetzt auch paige und unterstützen
das ist eins der neuen perks dort vielen
lieben dank auch an die robert bosch
stiftung für die unterstützung bei
diesem video und immer vielen dank an
euch fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten mal
bleibt neugierig patrick